-Great to see you, Tracee.
How you holding up?
-I'm hanging in here.
You know, still in one piece
Still in the same place.
[ Laughs ]
-You look fantastic,
and part of what a lot of us
have had to figure out
is not only
how to look fantastic
on Zoom calls
but how to actually
do the Zoom calls.
-Now I know
how to set up lights.
I do hair, makeup, lights,
production, tech -- all of it.
It's all --
-You and me both.
You and me both.
Congratulations on the Emm
nomination for "Black-ish.
There must be a little extra
I don't know, jump in your step.
-You know, I didn't even kno
the nominations were coming.
So, I turned on my phone,
and because of what we're in
and my nervous system being shot
like everybody else's,
I thought something
really bad had happened.
-Sure.
-But it was a congratulation
blowing up on my phone.
So it's been -- it was --
it's really a treat.
It's like a really nice
bright spot
in the middle of this crazy.
People are like,
"What do you feel about
not being able to do
red carpet and everything?
I was like,
"I just want people to vote.
-Yeah, there you go.
-Not necessarily for the Emmys
Yes, I would love to win,
blah, blah, blah.
Really nice.
I would like everybody to vote
in the general election,
and not just for number one,
in terms of the president,
but up and down the ballot
-Yes. If anything, I think
everyone in the Academy,
everyone's Emmy voting rights,
should use the Emmy voting
as their dry run
for the general.
-Absolutely.
Absolutely.
You could use it as a dry run,
figure out
how to fill out your census.
That's another one.
-That's another huge one.
10 minutes of your life
affects the next 10 years, Seth.
What are you talking about
-Exactly.
There's very few 10-minute
windows that will affect
the next decade of
representation as an electorate.
-Yeah, that's correct.
-You are coming into your
seventh season of "Black-ish."
And I know you,
like a lot of productions,
are trying to figure out
how to do the show in --
again, not to belabor the point,
but, you know,
it is the time we're living in
How is it going so far?
-All we've done is a table read.
I was a little nervous about it,
actually,
because I was like,
"How is this gonna go?"
'Cause, you know,
our table reads are crazy.
We talk over each other.
There's so much
joking and laughing.
So I'm hoping it'll feel safe.
I'm a little -- you know,
haven't been around people
in a very long time, Seth.
-Yeah, I, uh --
I know that feeling.
I think the other feeling
a lot of us have had
is how prepared
were we when this started,
how prepared are we now.
Are you someone who can stoc
a house well in trying times
-Yes.
I'm generally a stock person
-Like, I like
a backlog of things.
I am a household that always
has extra batteries, per se.
So when the pandemic started
I was like, "I'm good."
You know what I mean?
I knew everyone was freaking out
about toilet paper.
But I was like,
"I've got it, I'm fine."
But I went on Amazon,
like one does, and I ordered
what I thought
was a nice roll of toilet paper.
And at first, it said it's not
gonna come for a month.
I'm like, "No problem.
I'm set for a month."
And then, there were delays.
They were like,
"Your toilet paper is coming
It hasn't come yet, blah, blah
blah, but it's coming."
Finally, it arrived.
Seth, I discovered I'm not great
at ordering on Amazon
things both to scale
and the amount of things
you will be getting.
This is what a regular toile
paper roll looks like, right
-Sure, yeah.
-I ordered a --
This is what I waited
2 1/2 months for.
This.
These -- Look at this.
-[ Laughs ]
Look at the size of this.
-They're shorties.
[ Laughs ]
-What is this gonna do?
This would last me --
-I think that's
for a doll's house.
Those are dollhouse --
-But I will tell you,
it says "The feeling of
falling in love with you,"
and it's three-ply
sheet bath tissue.
-Well, there you go.
I mean, once you're a three-ply,
it can be a lot smaller.
-No, it cannot.
-Do you find holding it
that you're falling in lov
with yourself even a little bit?
-No, I feel like --
-Probably because it's wrapped
-What is this? Like, what --
This is like three uses?
[ Both laugh ]
-Look, I am telling you,
you're gonna be blown away
And again, I have a little -
I have a small investment
in that company.
But I promise you, when you feel
three-ply, you are gonna -
The love affair you are gonn
have with Tracee Ellis Ross.
-This is -- look at this.
-Yeah, well, the other one
the one you have,
that's like a giant --
that's like a one-ply.
-No!
-Look, it has to be that big
-I am taking it apart, Seth.
I bet you this is at least -
this is at least two-ply.
Look at this.
This is two-ply.
Two-ply!
-Yeah. All right.
All right.
[ Laughs ]
Hey, obviously,
we're showing here
that we're both very good
at business,
but you actually have --
You have your own
beauty-line company.
We talked about it
last time you were on.
Pattern Beauty, correct?
How's that going?
Are you managing
to get anything done?
-Honestly, yeah.
It's gotten a lot more
focused attention from me,
'cause usually I'm doing
so many other things,
and I'm on set.
We launched
our styling products,
which was incredibly successful,
and we were able to stay ope
during this whole thing
because it's essential goods
shampoo and conditioner.
And we discovered that peopl
are still willing
to shop online.
People still need
to condition their hair.
And I feel like hair product
are one of the places
that you continue to be able
to feel like yourself
and, like, honor yourself.
You can do
a deep condition, Seth.
Do you know what I mean?
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-Try a new hairstyle and fee
like you've done something
extraordinary while just staying
inside your home safely.
-Well, look,
as my hair gets longer,
a deep condition sounds
like something
I never even
would've thought of.
-And you know what, Seth?
You also might want to,
when you get
to the ponytail phase,
you might want to do baby hairs.
I am sure you've spoken
to someone
or seen someone
with a baby hair scenario
like extravagantly placed ramen.
-Yeah.
-So you could have ramen noodles
across your forehead.
-Oh, so baby hair is that
sort of like flat to the brow?
-Yeah.
-The designs of --
you can make designs out o
all the little bits, that --
you know, the shorter hair
on the front.
-Yeah, the more you talk about
this more this sounds like me.
Hey, so congrats on the film
"The High Note."
Obviously, this was --
you know, at another time,
this was gonna
come out in theaters.
Now it's On Demand.
You play an iconic singer.
What drew you to this?
[ Both laugh ]
Tracee, what would ever would've
made you want to play --
-It's a world
I wanted to explore.
-Sure.
-That I knew nothing about
that I have had no access to
-[ Laughs ]
-No, I was drawn to the role
I love the story,
and this character, Grace Davis,
although I understand that
like, an iconic superstar
singer, makes people
think of my mom.
But she's nothing like my mom.
And I got to sing, Seth!
I got to sing!
-Well, that's the crazy thing!
So, even though your mom
was Diana Ross, you had neve
recorded songs before.
-Well, my mom
is still Diana Ross.
[ Laughs ]
-Okay.
-She -- All right,
I spoke to her earlier,
and she said, like, where --
she goes, "Tracee
is my acquaintance."
[ Both laugh ]
-I just met my mom
during this pandemic.
It's been amazing.
She is so sweet.
No.
Yeah, I had never -- I didn't --
like, dabbled in the singing
but I'd never gone
into the recording studio.
And I got to record
four or five songs,
and one of them, my first
single, "Love Myself" --
Did you hear what I said?
I'm gonna say it again.
My single.
My first single.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-Sounds crazy.
I'm a charted artist.
I made it onto
the adult contemporary charts,
and I made it
all the way to number 14.
-Number 14?
And, look, I have been given
the power to make you an offer
We would love to license
"Love Myself"
for this three-ply toilet pape
that we are using...
-Oh.
-...that makes you
fall in love with yourself
[ Laughs ]
♪♪ I forget when I was young
it was easy ♪♪
♪♪ Toilet paper was this siz
now it's small ♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
That's wonderful.
All right,
we'll just steal it --
we'll just rip it from that an
use it in the next ad we cut
Hey, it is always such
a pleasure to see you.
Congratulations on everything,
Tracee,
and I look forward
to the next time already.
-Thank you.
It's so good to see you, Seth.